time wow that would be crazy wouldn't it
well might we well maybe well
possibly reaction 60 percent
i feel like 60 is the sweet spot we're
live we
should be live we're live and thriving
do you know the deal tell us that we're
live when you could hear us
tell us that we're live validate us
let us know you know how we do you know
how we do
yeah whoa john there's an echo going on
in our room sorry
you can hear us you can hear us kevin
shepard call some people out right away
we want to make sure today
is a good quality live stream but also
efficiently done
uh so we got kevin shepard in the chat
here thripster michael b
judas cameron iva melanie
eric horseman of course the pro 24 iva
also if this is your first time here let
us know i know we usually do this at
like 5 p.m
so sometimes if we go a little bit if we
go live a little bit earlier
people in other countries might be able
to
hear us or catch our live stream hey
from
the holy duck from new zealand here body
rot
anissa loving this loving the pink shirt
ramone what's up buddy disney logan
melanie of course sophie cooper
shouts out to germany my goodness
germany chamonix
kit trick mirna bradley bledsoe yes yes
anissa got me this shirt i lo i wear
this shirt at least once a week chill
level tv
dinosaur vegan oh my goodness if you
guys if
for the future communicating to the
future for the people who watch the
playback make sure to pop out the live
stream chat so you know what we're doing
there's like who the hell are all these
names that they're calling out right now
they are the people of the reject nation
this is not your first time
live streaming here with us and nissa
you're a freaking
liar you're not a virgin to this process
we got poland we got ali john
dude poland is my favorite place on the
whole country of poland that's where we
should relocate
the championships streaming every polish
person yes
you know kanye in the chat yeah
hey man vice president kanye
dang all right we got so many go all
right so today's gonna be a fun one
thank you
thank you what's up dan you keep saying
ding oh no just hello to kenya
also by the way absolutely what's up
racodeo and alex watching from spain
what's up in kenya and spain damn all
over the world people be watching
all right gents let's try to listen to
each other today for the first time ever
in a live stream let's try to actually
hear each other out
go back and forth on what we're talking
about um
oh look more comments happy birthday
rosie
is it rosie's birthday is it rosie's
birthday really we owe you a happy
birthday
happy birthday rosa birthday to you all
right
stuff and things what's going on um yeah
i thought today would be a fun live
stream thank you to everyone who's here
if this is your first time here
welcome um we're very uh off the cuff
kind of stream today we would like to
wrap this one by like 4 20 to 4
30. we'll see how that goes but that
that is a goal for us since we
tend to go like a half hour to an hour
over time
um but yeah today's live stream is just
going to be a wacky one what character
should have their own
youtube channel we'll kick our own
personal choices
off first and then we shall segue
into it but before we do let's act like
a this is a real professional live
stream
john how's your day going oh goodness
wow it's just been
the best it's been a terrific day there
have been many hours minutes and seconds
in it and i've done a lot of activities
i've used my brain to focus i have moved
my body circulated my blood breathed a
little bit it's going well how are you
greg how's your day
greg is good john greg is good i keep
going to bed way too late at night
because i
keep going down a wormhole of people who
do
amazing celebrity impressions okay
that's been the main thing keeping me up
at night a lot of ross marquan different
he's great just when you think you can't
get enough of ross marquan you find a
new video where he suddenly whips out of
jeff bridge's impersonation
and then you're like damn here we are
it's now two
three in the morning okay
so that's that's why we have to end at a
certain time i want to make sure i watch
my three hours of impressions
yeah but um all right who did i put in
the thumbnail
okay i'm gonna i wanna figure should at
least name off the people who i put in
the thumbnail then
of course we're gonna i want we wanna
read through what everything you guys
are
talking about in the chat i've already
seen a lot of really fun ones here
but um to give you guys an idea of what
we've been thinking here
because it can be easy to just say a
name which is fine say a name just
submit a name
but i think the easiest one for me and i
think what most of us will probably go
to
are like movie characters which makes
sense but
personally if you guys have seen the
hannibal tv show with mads mikkelsen the
lead role
so many episodes are dedicated
to just like a beautiful borderline
sensual cooking show it it feels like
i think hannibal could have his own
how-to
channel on cooking and specifically
how to cook human flesh to taste
like different dishes different types
life hacks right people
life hacks cannibals literally that's
what you could call it you guys
hannibal's life there you go
and so i think mads mickelson's hannibal
would make the perfect youtube channel
for a how-to cooking of the human flesh
to taste like other ones because
let's face it eighty percent of the
reject nation's demographic are
probably cannibals so we gotta tend to
those audiences and i really
think that that's what we need john who
is one that you have in mind
oh golly um i was so wrapped up in
listening to you
that i came up with one all by myself
too and that one
is uh oh i was good it's a really good
one and i'm gonna build suspense for it
because i really want you to know what
it is i guess i'll start with just one
of my backup ones then
um i feel like uh uh pete campbell from
mad men would be the first person to
start their own channel like
i thought about yeah a lot of different
things which actor is pete campbell pete
campbell is the guy
played by vincent cartheiser from also
buffy angel
yeah i want to make sure the audience
knows who this person is that you're
talking about
yeah so he's kind of a wah-wah kind of
character
and uh but he's got that like endless
confidence and he's oblivious enough to
always assume that what he's saying is
right so
uh he seems like the perfect kind of
character who would want to like you
know
make some kind of channel where he's
doing like halls of
suits and stuff and like sharing
marketing tips for people and like
really trying to
you know be the boss that he can't be at
the office through his own sort of like
motivational youtube channel
slash you know again gentlemen you know
like for the high-class gentleman kind
of thing
also talking about watches and attire
and whatever
yeah um yeah that was one who's the guy
who who leads mortal kombat who's is it
shang
is it his tournament yeah he's got a
youtube channel i think
because you know you gotta do it like
the shmodown which is the touchstone for
all things fighting
uh where you know you got stats you got
different fighters coming
in to talk about fights you know you got
videos of all the fights
so it's like a sports channel yeah it
would be a lighting channel a
fighting commentary channel yeah
supernatural fighting commentary it
would be
shang and shao khan yeah and they have a
commentary channel and they break
down the fights you could do that where
you have them in character yeah they're
doing
uh you're watching other people's like
gaming uh
versus live and then you're commentating
on that see
that could be a real thing now yeah
exactly that's my point there we go
that's why
that's why i wanted you to have that i
appreciate that john
one at some point the one i was
originally thinking i was going to come
back and it's going to be good
who are we seeing in the chat right now
just from the ones that are being
going off of here freddy krueger's sleep
problems is that
is that youtube i think freddy krueger
could have a great one
uh talking about dream interpretations
of
freddy krueger dream interpretations
well when you really get into
it yeah blow your subconscious mind
i see a few people have said this but
the pro 24 uh michael scott would
definitely have a youtube channel
yeah that guy would be making michael
scarn sketches
left to right when you guys are saying
names
say what kind of youtube channel it is
too yeah i love to hear
like you know we get a lot of names in
here but i would love to see like what
what
what kind of channel you guys are
specifically imagining
four uh that love that whatever you have
in mind for them
uh jordan peele us asmr what does that
mean yeah but
enrique the juice box just said it um
peter parker having a blog
i feel like that actually works already
because of the way
how spider-man uh homecoming started
with peter parker
vlogging it but i actually went back to
something i pitched originally on movie
fights forever ago
which was oh my god i'm forgetting his
name it's not daryl is it who who who's
the guy in team thor
who do you guys know what's up uh uh
damn it's not daryl what is the guy from
the team thor video where he's living
before he started living with the grand
master
is it daryl is it i think it's daryl it
might be daryl i said daryl i thought of
the guy from crazy ex-girlfriend but i
think it is daryl
anyway but yeah having him i think would
be a great like mcu youtube channel
oh yeah where every single episode he's
like
living with a new marvel character yeah
that would be a great one and then yeah
i think you could
just keep that honestly you know with
the lack of marvel production happening
lately that that could have been
something that they should be doing
in order to keep stay relevant dude
break into the new media man yeah yeah
quibby show that you could watch in
either orientation that's who i was
going to say
you know who should have a youtube
channel is morpheus of all the
characters in the matrix to have their
own youtube channel he seems like he
want to do it he seems like he would
want to you know what's the channel
it's a it's a motivational channel where
he also spreads conspiracy theories
and encourages you to wake up from your
life he's like russell brand
kind of but with more like you know
science fiction crazy like he'd have to
be off the grid you know posting these
videos you know kind of subversively
but yeah he'd be trying to like wake
people up and motivate their lives and
help him
unlock inner potential and of all the
characters in that movie i feel like he
would be the one who who actually might
just want to do that
for for just the sake yeah and uh
neo would have one video on youtube it
would be called become the one
boom that's how you become a mar an
expert martial artist right there
and even in the video saying captain
america motivational channel that works
too oh kind of like the
uh the life lesson the psa once there
you go from the end of homecoming
homecoming's where all the answers are
for
uh but i do see that we got some super
chats and i don't want to
make have people waiting for too long
because it tends to be a problem that we
do and uh so let me just get everything
loaded here um so johnny can you set us
up for that please here let me move the
mouse for you while i'm reading off some
quick ones
always can you just detangle the chord
yes john of course we're so polite when
the camera's rolling hey
thank you for not whipping me with a
belt for asking you to do that a j
jonah jameson blog that would work real
everything's spider-man related for the
ones that are really clicking with me
but one that is like a conspiracy theory
you could put pluck him out of the one
from far from home and just have him do
a youtube channel oh that would be great
you could just say essentially what the
character was suppose they were going
for and far from home
yeah i thought it was just sort of like
this video went viral on his like
because it appeared as though he was
doing an alex jones type show but from
you know like a live stream or something
you know buffy summer bloodlust
ooh so like uh so like a buffy
buffy's running a summer themed chant i
beat it out and then second drafted into
the comments
all right so what do we got today in the
in the chat who's niece is up first and
nisa
she really breaking us in yeah this one
okay you're right
i'm sorry i'm sorry e.t could have his
own channel
what thank you anisa really appreciate
it dear anisa oh
goody this was this was i agree already
jigsaw should have a channel so he can
show us
all his plans of how he did it and his
live streams would be showing the people
in the contraptions oh and his opening
line on every youtube segment is i wanna
play games i wanna play a game
actually yeah you said jigsaw yeah i
thought we were just gonna say something
along the lines of that like living with
jigsaw working with jigsaw and they
should just continue that but what is
you had a jigsaw one specifically is it
jigsaw or billy the puppet
there would be both yeah yeah what is it
your jigsaw one that you had in mind i
think
the the billy the puppet would do the
artwork okay like he would host
like some kind of more game oriented
thing but first off i think it would be
a lot of engineering stuff i think john
cramer would be showing you how to make
machines of various kinds
but also have like a will it blend
property where like every time he makes
a new machine
he tests it out on like a watermelon or
something to demonstrate how devastating
this could be
to the human body and then yeah billy
hosts the live streams you know people
tip for torture and stuff yeah be
perfect
that's great i like it john plus you
know you could have uh
john cramer with the stuff that he makes
he's got to have like some predilection
for like rube goldberg
machines so i think he'd have some viral
like just rube goldbergs like machines
he
creates that aren't for torture i think
he'd want to get that passion out there
for people too you know
okay john you are a creative guy
and i appreciate that thank you you are
an encouraging chap
and i also want to encourage people who
are part who are in the live stream chat
right now
that if you if anyone suggests an idea
that you really like
make sure to give a comment back to them
let them know that you like that one you
know
show them that like yeah that's a funny
one or something like that let them know
that you would want to see that one
we got joe o'keefe next wesley wins from
harry potter obvious choice hello from
ireland
usually catch this playing video games
on sundays oh
well thank you my friend hey okay john
who's wesley wins you're the harry
potter and he's really wins
is this a is this an actor or is this a
character i don't know a wesley
we're looking it up we're looking it up
in the meantime while john's looking it
up
all right rick grimes walking with
walkers hey
and that's a funny lifetime show oh
i think there's a typo i think you mean
the weasley twins no
yeah yeah yeah because i think they
would otherwise i'm just hijacking you
no there's a lot about wesley oh but
there's nothing about
harry potter wesley so wins game four
you're right
yeah uh weasley twins from harry potter
oh yeah dude they would be
oh that would be great prank tutorials
prank videos they would it would be the
combination literally of a prank channel
but also like a tutorial channel where
they teach you how to do the prank after
everything it would be so easy for them
to set up hidden cameras so they could
just block them with spells
yeah exactly you get harry to
participate you put him in an
invisibility cloak to walk around and
get really close-up shots
then we would have known for sure if
rudy giuliani was touching himself or
just putting his hands down his pants
oh my with a perfect harry potter
hitting oh my
yes that's what we would we could have
had a hidden camera in his pants that
would have been
great i love that weasley twins channel
and i hope your day is going well i hope
your video games are
or your night i guess this is earlier i
appreciate that buddy
shouts out to ireland really quick i'm
just copying pasting that name that you
see highlighted there on screen to make
it's all good
oh okay that norman stansfeld and frank
castle thank you niraj krishnan
norman stansville is gary oldman's
villain character from the professional
and uh frank castle of course the
punisher what the hell will their
channel be
i i don't i mean norman stansfield has
like a
big enough just like ah personality that
i feel like he would
be on camera for some re i feel like he
would just be ranting about [ __ ]
honestly
whereas like frank castle i'm not sure i
feel like it would be a lot of videos
if he was doing it it would be videos
about guns
and just like him taking guns apart
showing you reviewing new guns
it would be some kind of gun-centric
yeah it would be demonetized for sure
castle's youtube channel would instantly
be demonetized yeah
it would not follow community guidelines
like i don't think he would have
i guess the difference i would draw is
like i don't think he would be as fun
as like you know what happens if you
shoot uh
ham with a bazooka or something like i
don't think he would be doing his fun
stuff because i feel like frank castle
will want to respect
well actually there was a channel i used
to i watched like and i didn't used to
watch i watched a couple episodes of it
i think it was called sons of
guns it was like a reality show where
people would come in and be like hey can
you build me a silencer for a shotgun
and the guy that i've ever done that
before and then he'd figure it out so
maybe you can do that
yes yes we just want to see these
characters do tutorials
yeah you know because it's not as fun
watching them just go out on the streets
and doing terrible things
well because you couldn't do that on
youtube i think there does have to be
some
caveat of of like of
it's like jigsaw would never be able to
torture people on youtube i i
i grant you but if this oh my god it
would be the best click bait of jesus
but if you have
someone in a tree that's not the main
png carved out
if that's not the main topic of his
channel he'll get away with it but if
all you're doing on your channel is just
videos of you killing people i think it
would have to exist on the dark web i
appreciate this niraj thank you so much
and we got bernie alvarado who's next
bernie alvarez
bernie appreciate you you hear you've
been here like consistently for every
stream for the past few weeks or maybe
months
movie characters who would have a
youtube channel this guy did pop in my
mind napoleon dynamite
definitely did absolutely toby mcguire
and tony stark
you see i think tony stark easily could
have like a tech channel
yeah he could easily like show you how
to build stuff yeah right which would be
great
iron man yeah and then how to build the
iron man suit i built in the cave yeah
oh [ __ ] i put this youtuber dude for
four thousand dollars
you know like yeah or or he would you
would see him on hot ones too
yeah like you could definitely see tony
got a hot one
down junior in general hot ones tony
stark but tony stark like in the suit
but
just with his head you know showing yeah
i think napoleon dynamite just having
one of those real personal
like not not vlog as he takes his camera
to school but just
you know ranting to the camera he had a
great youtube channel
napoleon dynamite i'm not sure what toby
maguire's spider-man would be
he would just be a vlogger i think i
think he would just have like
i think he'd have a great instagram he
would have a great photos of spider-man
yeah yeah photos of spider-man and
science things yeah
movie characters become influencers
thanks bernie that's a fun one
all right let's okay who is this racket
to you
this is thank you racodeo raccadillo
thank you buddy he says uh i think john
wick
would have a great channel maybe show
off his gun skills his weapons of choice
how much it is to stay a night at the
continental
oh ooh or maybe like a continental show
ooh i mean they're doing that on stars
it's a narrative
he just introduces the women he's on
youtube yeah this is pitch web series
ideas now
uh john wick man i would be see he's
another one
i feel like he would do if i'm just
judging by the character he would do the
meditation asmr channel because he
doesn't like to talk a lot and
he's kind of soft spooking you know and
so like i feel like if he was just
like that's probably how john wick stays
as calm as he does
he probably has some amazing breathing
technique that he
does to like keep his mind zen and
focused and i think yeah
that that's what his channel would be to
me i don't think he would want to show
off the killing on the channel i mean
but
you know he would have the greatest
channel opening trailer right
or the biggest opening thing to put it
like the best opening to put at the
beginning of every video before
they roll the intro which is people keep
asking me if i'm
back yeah i'm thinking i'm back
yeah yeah that is right there she's
gonna roll the intro
it would be the perfect youtube channel
right there oh you know what else he
could have on his channel though is like
dog training tips
dog training tips you'd be the worst dog
trainer
here's how i have my dog killed and now
you want to have oh my god give away my
fight song on the nuts and no not like
halle berry sophia would have the best
dogs
they would have oh yeah
no no she would have a show with him
every week where they talk about dogs
she trains him and that's the the
conceit of the show
john you're such a good murderer but why
can't you take care of dogs
that was fun thanks um all right who's
next here
and he's uh anissa thank you anissa
ace ventura should have oh my god
eastern sure will lend himself perfectly
to a youtube channel
yeah of everyone is a new video about a
different animal or like
living actually i'm thinking of the the
the scene when you first go to ace
ventura's uh apartment
and then he opens the door it does
little jiggle handle thing giving the
signal for the animals to hide and he
goes there you see
he's got a gazillion animals living in
his little la home i think
if you had a channel that was always
about each one of those animals with ace
ventura
yes that would actually be a really
funny channel show you how to take care
of a certain animal
i like that how to take care of your
seal right how to take care of you yeah
every episode just how to take care of
your blank
also just going to acknowledge you now
radiator norman osborne how to be
somewhat of a scientist
not b.a.d
let's not do this oh no we did that one
all right
jigglypuff asmr for insomniacs
okay who said that tamara rhymes
with tamara rhymes tamara oh tamara
rhymes
with camera jigglypuff asmr for
insomnia oh my god that would be a great
one yeah oh that'd be a great way
just singing jigglypuff the whole time
actually it could be a good
playlist or not play was one of those
like 10 hour videos that you put on in
the background
yeah to just listen and go to sleep the
whole time yeah that would be yeah
it would just be one of those channels
yeah that's all about like three four
hour videos just to
lull you to sleep you know it would be a
lot of those like live streams like
infinite live streams of pleasant
sounds of jigglypuff i love that oh my
god i love it thank you
uh tamara with the camera uh tamara with
the camera but i
love this next one a lot i really just
at enigma
riddler himself i loved i'd like to see
patrick bateman from
american psycho holy crap
would that be good that it would be one
of those
channels you know like those youtubers
that you see that just come across
so like just ridiculously fake all the
time
yeah tara erickson in the chat but you
know but you know what i mean like
someone who comes together
but someone who comes across just so
fake all the time
and and then uh like it wouldn't be
about killing
his video wouldn't his channel wouldn't
be about killing it'd be like
you know how to take care of your skin
it would be a lifestyle yeah it would be
a lifestyle how to
how to how to dress fashion but
everything but everyone would just be
there's something off about this kind of
all the comments would be like there's
something really creepy about oh my god
if we had a lifestyle channel
how to invest in the stock market yeah
things like that it would actually be a
really amusing channel reviewing
different stocks of like business cards
you just know
something's up with this guy he would
know something's up with this guy
he would be a report of the day or
whatever he would he would literally be
like the creepier
more adult version of uh review bra yeah
of like a guy who eats food a lot
that yeah that's so funny in the suit oh
sebastian emonde sebastian iman
rocket raccoon what would rocket i i
like the idea rocker tech mods all tech
mods
oh my god like tech space box like
making weird
like you know appendages that have all
sorts of you know crazy abilities and
technology and stuff like that probably
he
i feel like he would be another one who
would have maybe just a small element of
prank to his channel because he likes to
mess with people but
definitely he would just be i think he
would like me on camera that's a funny
one
i really like that one a lot tara
erickson in the chat's getting a lot of
love for her amanda and yoda
youtube channel dude perfect it could
just be like taking the hidden camera
footage
uh from the razor crest with him yeah
the live feed of them chilling in the
cockpit and there's a lot of love for
bora bora
lends himself to a perfect youtube
channel already and by the way
we'll talk about borah at subsequent
movie film in a second i i really loved
it i had a great time watching it i
really did
um and then who's next here what's this
is kevin no can't
ignore kent mcnaughton our beautiful
australian friends
sending us this uh vibes vibes man nice
little sparkly i don't know
when the vibes were meant for but i
appreciate that buddy thanks
hope you're doing well buddy anytime
pull down mr mr sexy handsome face buddy
pull that window down and then we got
another one from anissa
saying the real rejects need an asmr
channel
just saying that's right where we'll
read
this copy of dune to you in a very
soothing tone
like i said i've always wanted to do my
own asmr channel to help people who feel
uncomfortable pooping poop
i would love to hear a sample there are
the kinds of things
that you would say breathe breathe
just put your hand on your stomach okay
now whip out your phone
now go on instagram go on twitter
just keep searching the web
and then realize it's been a half hour
and you need to get the [ __ ] off this
toilet now
try again later and then just edit in a
really big gap
and there you go yeah you're perfect
that's that's my dream vision right
there that's the one i love
and uh okay some quick ones from the
chat right here what do we got here
a goloman smeagle channel oh my god
there would be a golem
there should be like we'll be creating
like gollum if it was i
i want i've always wanted to see a
youtube channel where you do have
like someone who is like alt-right
radical left
and there's just those two on screen and
so it's just an even argumented channel
right
yeah and if like gollum and smigiel
represented one side of those equations
watch them talking about politics would
be hilarious everything
yeah uh let's pull this one up now
because we see some people gave it our
stream labs
uh streamlabs as well thank you
everybody's contributing to the stream
allowed us to take less fees so i really
do appreciate that
and then yeah and also just a reminder
keep sending love to whoever
puts one out in the comments in the
comments
one that you love you make sure to at
them
or just give them a good comment let
them know that you really do like
the one they have suggested forrest gump
vlogs
i like that one uh let me just pull this
run along with him
dean winchester trying different types
of food i like that that would be great
all right okay here it is i got the
beginning of it john all right we're
gonna pull up our stream labs right now
all right candyman and nick cage talking
bees all day yeah
i love that body rod just put that in
the comments and i just got that
handyman in the cage i'm talking about
the shot of him that is so
oh that is so funny i almost put you in
time up time out i'm sorry all right
there we go that is a really funny one
richard bentley tony stark
tech tips is what i suggested earlier um
let's go here okay we got some from
stream labs
and then is that right yeah do i have it
set up yeah it's time
for cache can i go closer or that mess
up the screen
i think you should stay here all right i
think
we we can try uh then our that's okay
our friend phleb doran thank you so much
our friend is also one of our patronage
he said uh hi guys just finished
watching the supernatural reaction when
i got the notification i appreciate that
dude
are most watched reactions three more
weeks till my favorite episode the
french
mistake can't wait all right well i
can't wait for that one either
me too
supernatural is a fantastic show
love love covering it and i appreciate
everyone who's at our patreon for it
like
thank you buddy bradley bledsoe the man
who i'm sure
one day will eventually edit for us with
the amount of dialogue exchange i have
with him back and forth
uh he is saying i think arthur fleck oh
here we go this guy's obsessed with
joker we
went on the discord chat with him just a
bunch of joker posters everywhere in
this room
he said i think arthur fleck should have
his own makeup tutorial channel
okay then i'm going to pitch you what i
think arthur fleck should do for his
youtube channel
you're going to like it the way people
all over the world can be
uh looking different looking fly in
different types of makeup whether it's
clown makeup or not
or not oh how to be like a fly looking
clown actually i think that's a cute
idea that's a charming idea
you know everyday clown makeup but
kenneth anderson darth vader breathing
techniques that's so good
really deep every once in a while i'll
catch one of the latest ones that'll
distract me
um i like that one here's my arthur
fleck idea that i thought he should do
he should have um like in his like cult
of joker world at the end of the movie
let's just say it takes place during
that time
right i have a very big fantasy idea
with it where he does
um celebrity interviews he's the host he
creates his
own underground talk show like
and then he asks a series of questions
and if he doesn't like the way the
interview concludes
based off of like it's like inside the
actor's studio but but it's more of like
a quiz based type of show like a game
show
and if he's not liking the way the
answers go he shoots them at the end
or he lets them live all right so that's
what my
arthur fleck youtube channel would be
i'm down come on
especially if you were to have him
talking to like really high-profile
criminals
yeah because then you could tie it uh
nefariously into uh the law or like kim
kardashian or whatever yeah
yeah yeah equal opportunities that would
be a fun one right
yeah definitely oh tm saying arthur
fleck dancing tutorials that wouldn't be
so bad
i feel like my arthroflex channel is
pretty [ __ ] funny
i'm down for that i think my arthur flag
channel would just be him making little
sketches with himself i'm just
just doing those little like one-person
sketches and you know
using his his notebook of ideas for
those comedic concepts
eric horseman thank you so much dude
always giving such
big big contributions really thankful
for that man thank you
uh lucifer morningstar from the show
lucifer
not peter stormer's portrayal of lucifer
and constantine
wow from the show lucifer they're so
different if you look at peter sir
matter
and for
is ridiculously charming and sexy yeah
and the other one is
lucifer morningstar because look at that
charisma and sex appeal oh there's so
much you could do with lucifer
you could have one where it's about like
how to run
hell you know well a day in the life of
satan is like
you know like a vlog in hell or how to
read people or how to manipulate someone
you know
things like that yeah yeah so much fun
he would
he would teach you cunning life skills
i just i'm sorry i saw one in the chat
that just said toby mcguire fixing a
this is door live stream how to fix it
that's all i until you fix the damn door
uh that's a good meme reminder keep
showing the ones in the chat
the comments that you that come up show
them some love show them some love
thank you thank you eric that's a really
fun one flev is back
joey tribiani love guru oh he would have
such a great pickup artist
joey on command joey
that would be a great that would be a
really funny one
joey trivia he had his own data i just
gotta say i love
all the topics i love this topic i think
this topic today has been great
yeah but if you actually had joey
gerbiani dude
i mean i feel like the way matt
leblanc's career is of how he just
pretty much
plays joey or himself which is like a
shade of joey
or people in a similar position to
actors playing
joey i think that would be so great if
matt leblanc just started up his own
joey tribiani like love guru youtube
channel
you know these like celebrities are
doing yes uh their own youtube channels
yeah matt leblanc should just do it as
joey tribiano
that would work too monica um sophie in
the chat say monica geller while on the
topic of friends
monica geller cleaning channel i see
jigsaw but he reviews puzzles and board
games do you want to play a game here's
my top 10.
yeah i i'm for that eric horseman back
at it again thank you
dude aaron i really do appreciate it man
um dance for you okay this character if
you haven't seen haunting a blind manor
this is where the character is from and
he is the cook for the blind man
oh and owen and he's he's one of the
best characters on
the the season of bligh manor and and by
the way i follow this guy on twitter the
actor
i'm forgetting his name but um he is
kind of
crude sense of humor and when owen
sharma
cookie like he's not afraid to just get
like super bold
an owen sharma cooking show with special
guest
hannah gross as his chef so he wants to
so what you want to do is take the
characters of bly manor
and throw them into a like oh and once
i need it i need to find funds to start
up my restaurant
so i'm going to start a youtube channel
to gain some popularity because at least
i'll get sensitive equipment and i'll
save money on that and then maybe if i
get popular enough people will start to
notice that everybody's so funny
and with his personality that would be
great he would yeah the the
the bad jokes would be very endearing
yeah i want his food
uh and then oh my god gnome in the chat
just said bran stark reacting to
showdown matches
he knows all i know who the winner is
none of these films had the best story
all right all right so
our friend cameron french suggested a
lot right here thank you buddy
let's see okay we're going to go with
one of these and i'll say which one
would have the best one
i'm going to immediately cross off
deadpool because i feel like deadpool is
such an obvious one
so i'm gonna go one of the harder ones
all right so he's saying deadpool
dewey finn from school of rock lloyd and
harry from dumb and dumber
the super troupe oh i'm already have a
leaning
derrick zoolander oh that's a great one
though
elliott moore from that happening oh for
me it's a toss-up between super troopers
and derek zoolander because
super troopers i mean if you have like a
highway patrol
oh youtube channel that would that would
go
really well and the amount of people
they pull over with the with the body
cams and the hidden cams in their car
you could have a really and then also
within the making
at the station oh my yeah it's like
sound footage yeah and then derek
zoolander
having like a modeling a male model yeah
really great oh dude yeah he could he
could start stepping on that that
jeffree star turf that is funny thanks
dirk thanks cameron i really appreciate
that dude
i would watch a dewey finn music review
channel where he just [ __ ] about new
music
uh michael schofield uh phleb thank you
bud michael schofield doing an
ex-convict reacts to prison movies
wow steven hyde's school of cool uh
stephen high from that 70s show
who is a problematic personality out
here and how to
channel about being effortless
effortlessly
cool who's michael schofield again he's
isn't he uh wentworth miller isn't he
the one who's breaking
it is miller yeah yeah i
feel like you know that's funny doing an
ex-comic reacts to prison movies
hey that would be a really fun one
because the first thing celestia
is wrong is he didn't get the map
tattooed on his body
i think that would be great actually
because i i have gone down a lot of
those rabbit holes lately like watching
professionals react to movies
yeah i would be down oh that's a fun one
man also
wentworth miller low-key great writer
apparently
what has he written he wrote uh stoke
this film i've been meaning to watch for
years called stoker which i've heard is
amazing
how do you know he's a great writer
because he wrote it under a pseudonym
and then it came out that everyone was
like wow what
you see it you haven't seen it you
haven't read it you haven't
well i was but my astonishment at his
post writing is not illegitimate if you
haven't seen
i said supposed great writer oh oh now
we're going to play
now we're getting over john remembers
the details
we're going to play you don't worry you
can go back later tonight
this moment up and see if i am
lying or not uh let's see here all right
but
what do we got in the chat step brothers
quick ones real fast here
ooh how to ride a skateboard andrew
garfield oh that'd be fun
joel mayberry ron burgundy oh my god you
know will ferrell would
absolutely do a ron burgundy yeah i'm
surprised he hasn't done it just do a
channel where he reviews different kinds
of scotch
do it like irish people try but with ron
brown you totally see a ron burgundy
lifestyle youtube channel undoubtedly oh
yeah reviewing various luxury items for
the modern man
uh mustache tutorials vents as 17 ism i
did cook that kicking with hannibal was
the first one i i kicked off
i saw somebody said property brothers
but with godzilla
so so what's the idea like you godzilla
helps
people pick out a house and then
demolishes the one they pick out or does
it demolish the ones they don't
either way i'm here for it oh my god
elio constant
asmr prank asmr channel with it
i i you you had a slip there but now i
want to see an asmr prank channel
that's just what i want ernie loki prank
channel would be
oh spectacular the god of pranks that
would be the top spectacular
noah would top him wampa pv chandler
being how to be funny
you know what's funny about that is uh
one there's a sketch that um
matt matthew perry did do on saturday
night live where
it was like a sarcasm class so they kind
of already did that
hey uh but yeah we do got some more
super chats that i want to make sure we
honor but let's see what's another one
that we got in here
a good one corgan body rock corrigan
meek
gaming channel that would be really
funny you just gotta have them do
voiceover
or you can have like one like a little
when they're like a little box yeah
that'd be really funny
damn i just respond stop killing me
daily affirmations with buffalo bill oh
my god
am i going to achieve my goals today i'm
going to achieve my goals today
let me read off another one here jason
makes a video every friday about how to
kill people
jason should have a video that uploads
jason voorhees should upload a video
every friday the 13th
yeah it's just him standing yeah for
five minutes
or three hours however long really all
right let's let's pull this up all right
we've got some more super chat stuff
here
stefan yelp reviews absolutely oh my god
stefan that that bill hater character
should have
damn we got a few we got a few thank you
to everyone who's contributed my
goodness
a handful we got
really sincerely thank you to everyone
who's contributed here
lucy john you take this one away all
righty lucy from peanuts should have an
advice channel like dear abby
for youtubers put that psychology degree
to good use
join her channel submit your question
and she'd be making more than a nickel
person
watch out dr phil ah that that would be
if if the peanuts kids were like coming
up now that's exactly what she would be
you did all the work for us yeah we
literally have nothing else to add on
that's a perfect pitch well done but
yeah and then you but you could also
have like guest star channels from
other people from the peanuts gallery oh
yeah yeah to come on her
youtube channel which would be great
right yeah you know peppermint patty can
come on talk sports
linus can come on talk about the latest
blanket news yeah it's her channel but
uh yeah you have the other ones oh
that'd be really fun
yeah yeah uh thank you melanie
pete dawn thank you pete how you doing
buddy
pedro d he's been one of our longest
patronage and my dude
for someone who is a writer this guy
works on like a gazillion novels at a
time
i'm so surprised that you haven't some
you didn't submit something i thought i
really thought you'd have something like
really creative to put down here i know
what it is
i know what it is the invisible man
um no harry potter is in the
invisibility club
trolling us right now from from your
joke before
that's what it was what would the
invisible man channel be
you could hear him dude you would make
he would make he would make ghost videos
he would pretend they're real you could
do a uh invisible man
uh a youtube you can make that where
it's like you just do the voiceover you
have the camera pointing at a chair
you just gotta like cgi in uh a crease
in the chair yeah that way someone's
sitting here that makes it look like
someone's sitting
like there's a slightly moving around
with strings i think yeah yeah
you could do your own makeshift
invisible man channel if you wanted to
dude invisible man reacts
and just have the chair move every every
now and again but thank you pete don i
appreciate it anyway
mirna mirna uh dan dan
danden tonton yeah
john do your best alan rickman
impression severus
snape yeah we see the streamlabs we're
gonna go back to the streamlabs in a bit
sorry don't do that again i totally
interrupted you but someone was
concerned about their streamlabs
this is what happened take it again
snape do one more time you're gonna nail
it this time i feel it
seven a snape having a
science channel a science channel
worship hands
what was his class again uh potions
patents
okay so it would actually be a great one
yeah i mean
the thing is i mean snape he's always
looking through the fence against the
dark cards but he's a good potion i mean
he knows his potions it seems like
dumbledore i think as much as you know
he
he's not the perfect wizard we all want
to believe he was but dumbledore know
people's talents
and he knew that snape would probably be
good with potions so yeah he could teach
you how to make some cool stuff man
oh john there's again a lot of love for
nieces uh idea in the chat which is john
humphrey how to get a girl channel
i uh no grow your hair long look like
him
be yourself yes and and watch
the the the the the colorful fireworks
display of strangers
that's the secret right there yeah
pretend to be all modest and shy
come on the secret is the secret to act
like a kill
it's not happening i'm shy around girls
even though girls love me so much oh
my gosh that's right yes that's the key
that is the key you're giving over john
i used it on greg first to know if it
was a viable class or not and now i'll
be releasing it for 100
online 100 online yeah john humphreys
master class
speaking of anissa ghostface among us
game channel yes i am
for it how how would that go john uh
yeah well i mean take it away
i guess ghostface would uh
you know i guess it would have to be i
think it would have to be the type of
thing where ghostface
like surprise challenges a group of
people to the game and then
you know yeah and then you know as the
debates go
then ghostface you know like kills each
person whose character gets ejected
uh so then you gotta have it's like meta
so then you're trying to
you got like real people being like wait
a minute i think one of us is actually
dead
and then you know having to figure out
who's the real killer while you're
trying to figure out who's the game
killer and it's really annoying and
confusing because you're doing
the real and the fake version at the
same time
i think you did it thanks i'm gonna play
back the video later
to actually hear what you said and i but
i think you did and then you're going to
send me a voice text later
verifying whether or not i did it you
said it you said enough for a certain
extended period of seconds
so i i imagine that you got it down yeah
that's that's pretty much where i'm
getting out that's
that's how most points made work is if
you if you just satisfy the time
requirement you just say
more you're good yeah exactly just keep
talking
eventually people will tune out and
they'll agree and then jim joe keefe our
irish friend back at him
i mean the weasley twins yes youtube
channel could have endless possibilities
from the early films we could see them
vlogging
from class and hogwarts once they leave
we could see them testing new products
oh okay yeah we thought prank channel
yeah i'm still thinking
i like i like your idea yours sounds a
lot nicer and like a more positive
inducing youtube appropriate family
friendly one
ours was about really [ __ ] with the
kids at hogwarts and then really going
after slytherin and stuff you know
i thought that would be a really fun one
yeah i would be i think
all of the above are possible on this
channel because think i mean
testing new products test them in the
field also i'm
very sorry i got caught by gnome saiyan
who wants a brad pitt from seven doing
unboxing videos
oh that would be so funny that's a great
new
new pun new pin comment new pin
new pinned comment pin love for you
buddy we're happy to catch our eyes
yes while we're reading the streams
they really should do like an mcu one
really just
take advantage of the way they're able
to use their marvel actors like puppets
and force them to do these youtube
channels yeah it should be their
contracts in a really tiny print chris
pratt as
star-lord being able to do
review bibs i really caught up on the
bradford one you could absolutely i know
right
[Music]
oh it's good so i got a box today that
i'm gonna check
out now we're going to unbox this
this is what's up don't come over here
no don't come over here this box over
here don't come over here it's co-star
morgan freeman
joining me to open that box
[Applause]
oh we got a funko pop that's it it's
just a fun coupon
body though where's the rest of the body
rapid from 79 unboxing one is pretty
[ __ ] hard to talk that's a great one
and the star-lord one i'm just imagining
like the intro to one episode like hey
sorry this episode's late we had to get
this new album pressed into a cassette
tape
yes dude there have been some real gems
in this one that you guys have submitted
real gems seriously yes epic night
poop happy poop poop poop a poop
mcknight
poop mcknight a poop at night i can't
ignite a poop at night he's australian
that's what we're doing
hey man poop is fertilizer from what i
understand
so you know you can thank you for those
good wishes
we're growing pumpkins uh so the poop i
will
take is a sign of good luck air horseman
oh
e rick hi hip hippolyta or hippolyta
uh hippolyta i've always that's how i've
always pronounced that name hippolyta
from lovecraft country
can't say why due to spoilers but if
you've seen it
you know one of my all-time fave
characters
really appreciate such a large super
chat dude i wish i
let me see if i know who hit because
i've only seen the first two episodes
and i'm not remembering
anybody's name oh man i'm so far ahead
of you i'm into episode three alright
are you
yeah you already start episode three yes
do you like it
episode three yeah yeah yeah i do so far
i'm typing this john that's what i'm
saying man i don't i i
i was gonna spoil the show for me by
typing in hippolyta
i don't know who this is all right can't
go any further but i'm sure you're
correct
is she if i'm not mistaken is she in the
first and eric
just like say yes in the regular chat or
whatever if i'm correct is is she
courtney vance's wife
who we see like in the first episode
who's like actually there the woman he's
with
who he leaves and then you know like
is she in the first episode we'll figure
it out look at that yeah we'll figure it
out john
either way cool ah let's see here
oh my god gollum jewelry appraisal
that's pretty funny man
it's worth
[Music]
whenever i can't figure out how to
pronounce her name i just i just have to
look at the word camera
tamara with camera rhymes a camera uh
earth kid eartha kitts catwoman on
training your kitty
hey that is really cute
each episode that's an actual channel i
would probably watch and john you were
correct about that one
but that is an actual youtube channel i
would i mean with someone who owns four
cats yes
yes i would hey awesome dude i i love
that idea thank you
and i hope it has yeah all the 60s
aesthetics why hasn't someone just
done that as like a gimmick there's so
many that would be so popular there's
like so many youtube channels about like
your cat or whatever do a cause just
just cosplay as catwoman cosplay and
character
do a channel yeah yeah something like
that that would actually be something
that any youtuber can do and
anyone could do that edutainment people
edutainment
oh wampa pee in the chat woody toy
review not a bad idea right there
john widget that'd actually be really
cute john winchester's how to raise your
kid's channel
and get his kids taken away because of
that [ __ ] after their mother gets killed
yeah yeah neglect
run out of autumn don't be emotionally
available abandoned
if you got two kids leave one of those
kids to do most of your job
michael b michael burns omni media thank
you buddy
my god you constantly submit people who
i don't know uh do you know who this is
john
um uh you're gonna look him up yes but
not by just
do that right here let's just do that uh
oh man oh my god did you see wrestling
all right that's who he's talking okay
yeah yeah right ryan gosling from darwin
duck is who he was talking about
darkwing duck is rad so i'm with you i
watched dark wig duck it took me a
minute
all right gosselin mellow from dartmouth
been watching that series since the new
ducktale show seems to be setting up a
return for dark
weighing happy saturday boys how is that
new ducktales show
omni i don't know how you do it buddy
you just watch so many
shows like so many tv shows somehow run
a full-time job
and somehow run a youtube channel where
you're uploading daily
i don't know how you do it dude it's
very it's very impressive how you run
things man
yeah i mean i don't know you're a
prolific hands down
you're the only living soul i know
who is re-watching ducktales right now
because a new show is said is the show
is setting up this we gotta go back to
the origins of some character named
darko
like that is that's so bizarre to me how
do you do that man
darkwing duck is rad okay he's like a
detective he's harassment
oh my god no i mean thank you michael b
but niraj
this is a great one dude it's a most
excellent choice
most excellent excellent every episode
start with
how's it going ladies how's it going
youtube
how's it going youtube yeah bill and ted
music reaction channel oh that would be
brilliant yes
that would be that's a brilliant one
this new
that is brilliant this new track is most
heinous
i don't know how he's not a fan of the
production we not think of this
i you know that's why we got y'all
because you all are about to think about
it i know
damn that doesn't do good that's too
good yeah and it would start as music
and it would turn into anything because
you just want to see them react to
whatever
you know oh my god though think if they
did history reactions
time travel react to a historical event
in real time
all right michael going back to this one
michael b is saying the new ducktales is
the definition of how to reboot a
classic
all right then i'm gonna watch all of it
we gotta watch all the ducktales and
then we gotta watch the reboot so we can
understand the
statement that michael b is making every
day
i've been making duct tapes they do a
new song
colton underwood thank you dude thank
you borat and
bad grandpa hmm doing
doing what they do like just pranking
folks i mean borat
i mean thank you colton underwood uh but
borat doing his name but bad grandpa
i'm trying to remember what i mean
there's some hilarious or is that
johnny knoxville in the makeup no dirty
grandpa is
grandpa is uh johnny knoxville
my grandpa i didn't know you were close
with your grandpa yes uh my bad grandma
my daughter your father figure in so
many ways was her grandpa
okay i am my own grandpa one day i might
be a grandpa
but a bad grandpa one won't be fun but
him and this g him and the kid
uh like a little roach road trip
vlogging one would be a really good one
borat though perfectly lends himself
let's take them did you see borat yeah
i thought it was really funny i quite
enjoyed it i personally i it's one of
those movie
it's it's definitely more i think the
first one didn't really ma
like even though sasha barrett cohen has
usually been left-leaning his whole
career
um it didn't really matter i think with
the first borat as much
which side you swayed on but if you are
for the right uh
the right right wing side of things you
will hate that
the quite right yeah you will hate that
movie if you are into the quite right
way yeah
but you will probably be upset but uh i
did think it was hilarious i loved the
narrative there was some really
shocking stuff and i thought the way
they handled the narrative of the new
borah was actually surprisingly well
done
there's more i think plan bits
like planned sketches or improvised
sketches ones that are not like messing
with
uh you know going pranking people
essentially yeah
uh but i actually thought they did a
good job on telling his story like
i was actually heartfelt by the end yeah
like this is actually surprising i'm
getting the feels this is so surprising
yeah yeah but there's also some really
shocking it's nothing is like oh my god
the two naked guys fighting each other
but at the same time though there are
some really shocking bits and
like they they push it man they really
push it yeah
i was pleasantly surprised i thought it
was really funny yeah i mean they
definitely go for it
they don't it doesn't feel like they
just came back for something stale
like they they pushed that image anissa
we have seen this trailer
we did off topic but uh check out the
selena trailer we have seen the trailer
i think we covered on the the live one
when we were doing the live reaction
yeah
yeah i think we did cover it then so to
answer your question and your super chat
appreciate the super chat but yes we did
do it
random andy's channel random and hey
what's up also i think uh i think j
was rand is that andy the the guy with
the the great jaw yeah
yeah dude and that black and white hey
what is up
also i think james stewart's character
from rear window
would make a great youtube channel also
been busy got a cam to make videos
excited to see what videos you make that
would be a
wonderfully creepy one of james
stewart's character from rear window
it could be a vlog channel about his
neighbors basically yeah
he's never on camera he gets a camera
instead of just using the the uh the
what the [ __ ] why can't i think of the
word the scope telescope telephoto lens
that's what it's called oh you telescope
you does he ever
does he's a telescope he's using a
telephoto lens telephoto lens yeah okay
that's right he's like
using a really long all right see if he
had one of those but instead it was a
camera
it could just be about his neighbors it
would be super creepy not as
touch actually sounds very that's a
really weird idea i don't know what
what will be your channel because now
i'm filling in the blank here for your
channel
it would just be a very perverted path
just be a voyeuristic
live feed and and occasional photography
tips
i can't remember what's his occupation
from which he's christian
he's like is he just like a regular
photographer it could be a photography
channel
but yeah if he's just housebound it's
just gonna be a lot of creeping
ah let's see here
lewis lewis lewis ed from shawn of the
dead
hey janna how you doing hey ed from
shawn of the dead
um pre and post z word
yeah wait what so ed
before and after he turns who okay uh
nick frost
what would the channel be probably
gaming videos or something right
yeah okay that makes sense you know he
would probably be gaming zombie gaming
and then yeah you could be a zombie
gamer and then sean joins the channel
when
the zoo yeah the zombification of the
world goes down and then yeah they play
each other
oh that would be great yeah actually
yeah and then zombie reacts perfect
you did it thanks you pulled it off i
love shawn of the dead i'll make it
happen if i have to
oh i love this one i love this one
the daleks angrily reviewing american
politics so like
the far left the radical
will destroy america
mr president no no mr stop
stop talking about it stop as the man
q anon trump is a dictator we will
follow
we will follow we will follow
there you go you got to get that you got
to get that that weird indignance that
they have in there
that's really funny my goodness thank
you guys all right it's probably gonna
be over like a half hour more
so let's see what's going on in the chat
ooh kenneth anderson is saying in the
chat
ninja turtles best pizza i know we got
some streamlabs we gotta do too
and some more super chats but yeah we'll
just uh we'll go through the comments
here happy birthday again to rosie
rosie ninja turtles best pizza spots
it's actually a really fun idea
mm-hmm plus all the different things you
could do with pizza i feel like
michelangelo would probably have a
how-to basic style side channel too
doing like [ __ ] posting someone that's
thanos
how to shave channel which is an
interesting one
but seriously rosie happy birthday to
you dear and
i want to say this i i didn't properly
where'd my oppa go where'd my apple go
okay i got i gotta pull it up i gotta
pull it up oh
i wanna take the opportunity and let me
take the title away here
pulling it up pulling it up i just wanna
make sure i'm properly thanking everyone
pulling it up for for the opera because
i say katie ann but i misunderstood the
message when she first sent it to me
this is oppa from avatar the last
airbender wow
episodes in uh let's see here
uh yes yes okay
so who do we got here who do we got here
uh
uh okay so yeah mimi sued and rosie
thank you so rosie happy birthday to you
for me shouting out your name for
holding this oppa here in hand
but avatar the last airbender pretty
great show got
gotta say pretty great oppa appa
what about jarvis having a vlog channel
uh is it all like from the outer camera
on the front of iron man's face
i would you know what i would want is um
jarvis
and wanda having their uh a relationship
couples relationship channel
like tips on how to have a healthy
relationship i think so
dating an android a dating a witch you
know
yeah that's like weird thumbnails in the
bed like
just just had a baby yeah have their
kids in there
supernatural baby care tips a weight
loss channel with fat thor is not a bad
idea man
that's just viral marketing right there
uh jacob kowalski baking
channel finally bringing fantastic be
some love in the chat today about time
i've seen a couple newt scamander like
animal training vids as well
yeah it's a good idea it's a good idea
the kids from strange okay pumpkin had
to say love for certain the kids from
stranger things would be a great youtube
channel
absolutely they could do a d gaming
channel
yeah and then we'll be back
oh my god will is over here trying to
make dollars dudes starting a channel
and everyone else is like we don't care
i love that sl7 the hulk on between
two ferns would be spectacular
i'm for it i mean yeah i mean robert
down june and tom hollandhammer
i'm sure would be good tm jason todd
posting rant videos
would it be as jason todd or would be in
the red hood mask is it jason todd right
here which one are we talking about
uh red hood for me but yeah we talked
about captain america's uh motivational
channel so we got some stream labs to
wrap up here and then we also got
other because i got to edit some review
i got to edit my midsummer review the
reaction will be coming out from
midsummer next
this coming week actually but who do we
got in the super chats for
uh uh stream labs yeah okay we got three
right here
uh oop that [ __ ] it up all right so what
i'm gonna do because i see art x
no no no oh what's right here yeah never
mind ardex mills thanks buddy
martix means not mills means uh thank
you both
for talking about what you love and
sharing with us
i love milano cookies by the way i would
like to see the members of the umbrella
cat umbrella academy have a
dysfunctional family channel each
sibling can vlog on a different day of
the week
imagine ben just levitating the camera
oh that'd be fun or klaus always wanted
to be the star of the show
um oh and you watch them all do their
power actually yeah living
you could do it where they're actually
part of the umbrella academy and they're
training
inside of umbrella academy would be a
pretty fun one i think they'd all love
to be able to talk to the camera since
they were glorified celebrities as kids
john has no idea what i'm talking about
haven't seen the show
i agree yeah but yeah i think that would
actually
the umbrella academy characters having
their own youtube channel would be a
pretty great one i think you could do a
lot there
or you could do it from the dad and he
is talking about
how to have superhero children or
something like that
just different lifestyle tips to make it
more likely for you
to have 43 kids on the same day you
could do this i would actually say for
umbrella academy you could even do that
with doom patrol
the thing is i imagine like
mockumentaries that's where my mind
keeps going like
there's which there are there is like
you know documentary vlog like you know
follow them around with a camera which
are
in itself a youtube channel but i i keep
imagining uh
like for for we say like the shows like
do patrol or umbrella academy imagine a
mockumentary kind of show more like
office
which is not bad it would still be
pretty fun i think flev doran back at it
barney stinson
the broco channel oh that would be great
that would be controversial mr george
feeney doing a ted talk type of channel
i love both of those ideas too
a plus i mean barney stinson having his
own i think that would be hilarious
like the totally obviously
i mean you would have to know it's
satire but a sexist channel because
barney's pretty sexist i've been having
a bro code channel
would be funny and then more mr george
feeny doing a
ted talk type of channel george i'm only
on we're almost done with season three
of boy meets world olivia is really
watching it with me as i'm watching it
for my first time
and george feeney's words of wisdom have
like his empowerment his aw inspiring
ways of being a teacher
have gotten me misty-eyed or just
full-on cried
several times so i do think george
feeney having a youtube channel
where he is like giving words of wisdom
as principal feeny would be really fun
that's a great call that's a really
great call
tongue punch fart box back in the chat
hey deontay
hunting with craven the hunter oh that'd
be fun
think steve irwin but with craven the
hunter
uh tourette of talks cars dom talks
about his
oh toretto talks cars toretto talks cars
and then oh it could be like a family
show though you could do that like kind
of a reality show
kind of like that sons of gun show i was
talking about earlier where it's like
american muscle but it's like on the
history channel reality show
yeah talks cars would be fun dude you
can have them talk cars and then at the
very
end they can show you what best to have
at your family barbecue when you drive
this particular car yeah
yeah actually kind of like your toretto
talks cars idea a little bit more
than your honey with craven one because
that would just be brutal
but you can have like a body cam on you
hitting uh like a gopro would be fun
like it would be like a it would be like
a parkour kind of video if you did like
a craving
ravens parkour you've been doing parkour
through the
streets of new york hunting people right
yeah i think that's good yeah
i think uh craven parkour is a plus oh
my god wait i might
okay thank you so much everybody
submitted there we might have a new
pinned comment because i just need this
is a really great idea i'm just gonna
i'm not even gonna call it out i'm just
gonna re-pin this comment oh i gotta go
to the actual
chat right where that with the actual
actual
one sec guys i'm about to pin a new one
just because where where is
find his name i'm looking for body rock
there it is there it is there it is
i love this one from body rod in the
chat i'm gonna replace the pin one
this is the one mysteria reviews batting
goods cgi
that would be really funny clearly they
didn't have a team of people next door
animating this guy
oh i want it i want it all right guys so
we're going to do the last of the super
chats thank you to everyone who's
contributed so far but these are going
to be uh we're going to refresh this
window
mm-hmm and then if anyone contributed
and streaming allows us to do the last
of those
as well and then of course just
chit-chat for a little bit
but yeah got a uh a a friend dinner to
go to and then some halloween zoom thing
to attend
so interesting yeah interesting night
willy wonka candy reviews
i like that all right let's uh pull this
up
patience bobby
i just skimmed uh tamara's
one that we're gonna get to and i think
that is so funny
okay i can't wait to read that one out
of you guys that is a really funny one
you all are
you guys are cool thanks for all showing
up oh my god that is so funny
i like it i like it i like it okay okay
here we go uh
all right one second
all right uh anissa sam from
thank you anises she's got two back to
back oh
let me read this one first that's a
great one truman from truman show
there's only like what you say truman
and he's like you just know which one
you're talking about president henry
truman yeah harry harry harry sherman
president
truman um truman having a conspiracy
channel is actually a really fun one and
it could be within the truman show
yeah because thinkers before he realizes
he's in a reality
oh my goodness this is the ultimate
conspiracy he's been trying to uncover
the greatest conspiracy
guys we are living in a reality show
then he finds out he's the only one
who's living in the reality
oh my god but then think what that would
do to somebody's mind if you if if
like oh confirming even one of those
conspiracy theories just the fact that
he is in a reality show that will make
it like
his credibility so much that's so funny
it'll lend so much credence to all of
his theories
and then sam from trick or treat having
a halloween channel
oh but what would that be though what
would he
like what would his halloween channel
consist of
crafting i guess like i don't know like
teaching you how to make like little
things to make halloween
decorations on your own like maybe like
an apple severed head or like a
or like uh one of those jack-o'-lanterns
you can make out of like a pepper
you know how there's chant you know what
i think sam from trick-or-treat will be
a great youtube channel
you know how um uh you have your horror
channels that distribute
um horror short films channels like
crypt tv channels like altar
i think if you did that one for sam but
he he served as kind of like a crypt
keeper
or um a rod wait rod sterling sterling
sterling yeah there's just no t yeah rod
yeah i was like it's not sterling is it
no
right if you had like a rock like a
rockstar but if you had sam as kind of
like
that uh that kind of character to like
introduce you to the tales
and everything pretty great and it was a
trick you call the channel trick or
treating sam's trick or treat and then
every episode would go into the horror
episode that would be pretty great
and everything has some kind of
halloweenishness about it i would
yeah yeah so you just distribute films
like that all right here's tamara's john
read that
batman just saying i'm batman
every every upload every upload is just
him with the phone
not even like yeah just like this
and the video title is just i'm batman
the description says i'm batman
like celebration video he gets an
updated mask and says i'm batman i'm
funny
that is that is really funny april
fool's day he says i'm superman
different locations if i'm just going on
batman i
i think a meeting with the justice
league he's at the table
i'm batman this is aquaman eating a
sandwich in the background
i think that ought to like someone has
to have the means to make that applause
channel too man it would be
super cuts forever let's see
anissa ross having a relationship advice
she'll be the worst
now when you're on a break
it was slowly turning how i found love
after three divorces
it would slowly devolve into just like a
tell-all podcast where he just gets
drunk and talks about his love life and
then he would start a secondary channel
about paleontology that would get
nowhere
ooh in the chat leo i just caught this
one jumanji let's play
that's great yeah go strap him with a
gopro
that's so funny all right
the avengers plays cards against
humanity
it would be fun that would be it would
be fun
it depends who you have there yeah i
think drax would be
the best person to play cards against
humanity with because he can't tell the
difference between sarcasm
you know so you know that half the time
he'll probably say something actually
funny and then half the time it'll be so
inappropriate that he'll probably be a
dark horse and win the game it would
actually be a really funny sketch
yeah if uh like everyone's laughing all
the time and drax is the only one who
doesn't get the jokes
you get drax on there you i would want
doctor strange playing just like
constantly checking reality so what the
funniest answers are actually yes
tony wins yeah and then the whole kiss
you don't want to play with the hulk
because he's just going to freak out
oh that's funny yes and then and then
clint just never gets picked
his cards never get picked and then uh
oh thank you anissa oh thanks
loving the new real rejects logo yeah i
tried a few different things out
the guy forever ago i put out um
a tweet being like i can't find the
original email of the guy who made the
logo for me that was because he just
like gave it as a gift
years ago and then he finally found me
he
came to the manger where you yeah
yeah uh jayden barnes and
um and he sent me like uh the graphics
for each one of the items and then i
just
toyed with it like that that is it's
actually the same logo
i just like did like a melting effect to
the to the uh
to the film reel yeah then i really
punched up the real
because i realized that on notification
bells you can't even make out our name
it just looks like something it's a
reddish just like a red
yeah it's just something like it just
looks like fire fire in a circle
it doesn't really stand out we need the
real reject thing to pop so that's what
i made it to and then it ended up
turning into like some
90s t1 000 looking thing
but thank you oh this is fun this is
really fun
um eric horseman thank you buddy
parenting tips with annie graham from
hereditary
and every video starts off so well and
then by the end of it it's screaming
everything's on fire yeah
they start off normally and then
somebody enters the room
and they get into an argument and then
it's just like they forgot to turn the
camera off every time that is funny
sophie's saying lauren sophie had some
great ones today lorraine warren ghost
hunting channel
if you had uh if you have both of them
the warrens
that would be funny and have them go to
the same locations every ghost hunting
channel
skywalker relationship advice and
against skywalker pod racing tutorials
yeah i'm surprised there hasn't been as
many like
yeah like mannequin skywalker and this
is pod racing
or like you know like star wars jedi
training tips
[Music]
how to be a jedi history of jedi like
multiple playlists of how to be jedi
imagine how many motivational one up
emperor palpatine no he could be the
jordan peterson of the internet where
he's got like a lot of theories that
people agree with but some pretty
radical ideas people
don't and then you have like qui-gon
jinn over here making like
do a star wars universe of all these
different channels yeah how to how to
sith
yeah how to sit
oh jedi meditations
all right gungan asmr if a voice in your
head says
kill him you kill him all right
relationship advice
with danny from mid samar so what you
got to do is you got to join a cult
take your boyfriend to a cult and let a
lot of people share your emotions with
you
and uh have him have some friends who
can get lost
that's a really fun one thank you i like
it thank you buddy i would be
i would be cons i would be fascinated to
hear what her advice would be before and
after the dream i would actually be more
curious with a midsamar
um youtube channel based on the uh the
the the cult there yeah like a youtube
channel vlog
about the cult and minsamar would be fun
i want
it random manny's channel hiccup would
make millions with his channel oh my god
he would exploit the [ __ ] out of those
drafts oh my goodness
you know hiccup would be just a cash
crap you only got the dragons for the
views man
yeah everyone
how to abuse your dragon dragon [ __ ]
fighting
vikings are actually terrible human
beings you should invite
support this channel cancel vikings
how to survive groundhog day is a pretty
funny one
i love this topic because you guys have
shown so much of your own personal
creativity so that's why i've
really been loving this topic anakin
makes a 20-minute rant video about sand
i have a few things to get off my chest
i don't feel i've said enough on the
matter
don't like sand all right what we got
here
uh tamara uh tamara with the cam rhymes
with the camera
voldemort how to speak to snakes and
where to see them
youtube that sounded like a picture oh
so like how to speak
pop par parcel tongue parcel tongue yeah
it's not personally how this sounds like
a word christophe walton's how to speak
parcel like a parcel like a like a box
who's on first
parcel tongue voldemort how to speak to
snakes
where to see them oh i just got the joke
had a yeah
fantastic snakes and where to speak to
them from
that'd be fun yeah i like it i'm down
your batman one is still your best
you're batman
that's my
[Laughter]
and think of the cameo potential too
like people hit him up on cameo batman
can you can you send me a camera oh
every single one it's the same thing
that's the same [ __ ] every time yeah
it's a live stream just uh
batman it's a four second live stream
all right so we caught up on the super
chats are here thank you to everyone
there i'm just checking the stream labs
to make sure we're caught up on stream
labs and we're just gonna stick to the
regular chat for a few minutes uh but
yeah we're all caught up yes we
are sincerest thanks to everyone who's
contributed
all around you and all those glad we're
calling the first time we're on track
what
this is what happens you create a time
limit what happens when you create a
time loop
let's see what you guys are saying here
in the stream let's do it
only at the stream right now only at the
stream thank you to everyone who's
contributing super chats but only stream
now
bruce wayne parent counseling oh
goodness
oh that's fun ooh i saw i saw one with
john rambo doing like survivalism tips
oh my god bradley bledsoe just suggested
one anakin making an apology video after
already
order 66. look i'm
i'm sorry i take full responsibility for
what i did but it wasn't my
fault all right i was going through a
difficult time i have mental health
problems
i lost padme you know
you do all the the ways you don't
apologize
yeah yeah yeah yeah and and working
influence
of the dark side at the time it wasn't
my fault it could happen to anyone what
about what about what palpatine did i
think cancel culture just ruining
everything
we need to learn forgiveness out yeah
what's how much is enough
when have i lost enough uh
groot learning different languages
that's a fun one
and it's still just i am groot
but you know with different accents
that'll be the the nonsense of that bye
steve bye flav
definitely a mclovin dating channel tm
is suggesting harley quinn beauty
channel
complete with voiceovers oh yes yeah
with her talking to you but then also
her own voice over
this is what i would want uh what's
another one hashtag anakin is over
anakin is over party oh gordon ramsay
food champ i'm surprised he has done
that already
um i mean toy how to build a time
machine with doc
if you had doc brown and then you got
marty behind the camera you got
yourself a youtube channel ready to go
yeah you have a time traveling one with
them
actually ooh yeah if you did that i mean
then you got a series
i see oh that's how you reboot back to
the future
hey we correct we did it i figured out
how you reboot back to the future right
yeah once this semeka says it won't
happen
i see one about odin how to how to
banish your kids i feel like odin should
have the parental
uh counseling yeah anybody
i wanted i i missed those videos i
wonder if they still do that when they
had like
boyfriend confront a girl girl confronts
ex-boyfriend about cheating
you know like and they just have them
sit across from each other it's like
really raw confrontation yeah it's
really
awkward uh they should do that with odin
and his children
and hella having to talk to each other
yeah
i'm i'm i didn't mean to banish you uh
what did ethan morgan say carry on how
to surpass high school
yes yes make her the beautiful that is
beautiful
make her the girl from eighth grade we
did talk about a joker makeup channel
that we did
yeah and a maniac spring channel yes
this is which is essentially animaniacs
borat has been the number one most
suggested borat has yeah it's
because he or he hit the movie in show
already lend themselves to essentially a
youth
essentially a prank channel already you
know i just saw one that said walter jr
cereal unboxing
walter junior plus he could move on to
other breakfast foods
he could be like review bra as well and
just review different microwavable
breakfasts
avengers cast having a youtube channel
of course
seinfeld doing true crime narrations
oh no no that would be
that would be uncanny let's get a couple
more in here let's see what we got
oh my god oh i would love to see like a
leather face
version of a makeup channel because he
keeps makeup on them
you know all right dog interviews about
their family and friends
ethan freddy krueger on how to get a
good sleep schedule
uh it's gonna be really important what
you're gonna wanna do first
sleep hygiene so you're gonna wanna get
all the electronics out of the room
before
at least an hour before you go to sleep
how to be a good boy from a peter quinn
that's that's adorable eric i appreciate
that one
um but yeah how to make 100 ways to make
potatoes with mark watt
oh my god epic dvd came with a great one
jason voorhees
like jason reviewing different campsites
oh my god
if you did a nature channel like a
christian's type channel i forget what
his channel is actually called like why
a wonderful wilderness or something but
where it's just jason
and it's just he's just recording shots
of him walking through different
campsites
all over the country and just like
standing in them
yeah like do do all the benefits of one
of those travel vlog channels but with
no commentary whatsoever
oh my god and then the horrible bosses
cast like a
cast on how to kill my kill your boss
youtube how to kill your boss and get
away with it perfect
wampa pv this is my new favorite the
hank mineral
the hank schrader mineral review where
he finally goes to the minerals
they've done like [ __ ] jesse and walt
learning how to make uh
cooking meth yes jesse and walt cook and
meth channel i want
a channel where skinny pete and badger
show you how to build like a tree house
i just want a skinny pee and badger how
to be one of the second show on the
channel yeah exactly
yeah everyone from the breaking bad
you're gonna have a lawyer show with
uh better with assault goodman yeah
legally
it's all good where instead of trying to
be upstanding it's all like shady it's
all how to be a shady lawyer
and all the advertisements on the
channel from saul himself
yeah yeah that would be great or lost
hermanos oh my god okay so we got um
we got one more um super chat to honor
and then we're gonna call it a day dia
oh i need to refresh this first all
depends on the honest trailer to be
honest chelsea brown i'll let you know
chelsea be co-teaching kung fu that
would be adorable that'd be a great kids
channel
that would be the most expensive kung fu
tutorial
okay this is a good one to go out on
okay you guys are gonna like this one
there's a good one to go about it i love
this
this one oh thank you dark menace
homelander reviews
best
a bunch of different moms submitting
breast milk and he just reviews which
ones are the best breast milk
and then think of it he'll advertise
pumps
they do an interview while pumping and
then after the interview's done he tries
the milk
that's great oh thank you dark menace oh
that's fun
oh all right guys beautiful thank you so
much to everyone who's been here i
personally
really love the uh you guys showed up so
much creativity here
this is why this was a wacky one y'all
really did love it and you guys still
have so many countless ideas
live stream chat to go through wish we
could go through them all
thank you to everyone who's contributed
to our super chats and stream labs of
course
i hope you're being safe out there um i
want to say
a special thank you to the people in
colorado right now with the terrible
fire that's happening over there because
those firefighters are like there's a
lot who have been actually
um staying there when they're being told
to that they should evacuate because
they still
they believe they can just keep putting
the work in there to help minimize this
i
i don't know if it starts snowing yet
it's supposed to snow tonight but the
fire is spreading like crazy
so there's a lot of brave people out
there who are fighting their asses off
and there's so much love and support
being shown in that community you know
it's like it's it's
so like in california i feel like we're
used to these fires right
and there's such a different type of
attitude than what i'm seeing
from what it's being tweeted out about
what's going on on the radio calls
the police and the firefighters there's
a lot of support and a lot of
heroism being on display right now great
spirit and courage being shown
so uh i'm gonna i'm waiting for like a
proper
thing to donate to for relief funding
once it's all said and done because a
lot of people's homes have unfortunately
gone down and also there's uh you know
some people have already died maybe they
rest in peace but send
thoughts prayers and love to the people
in colorado be
safe out there guys covet still very
real so be safe out there please
thank you so much for everything much
love to everyone and uh if you prefer to
us
going live at this time let us know in
the comments please yeah
thank you again we'll see you guys soon
love everybody have a good weekend